end of day one this is our final demo of
today and I'm joined by Michael for 505
games how you doing man great to have
you on stage hey you know three beats so
far it's been pretty busy man we've had
a lot of people out there getting
hands-on with the Sniper Elite and I'm
here to see Sniper Elite 3 brilliant
we've got a live demo to show you guys
actually right now so I think we'll just
cut to that straightaway and I'm just
gonna let you two talk away like where
are we what's going on what's you in
Sniper Elite 3 juggle at the moment
we're in Gaborone oasis so we draw in a
lot of the real world locations that are
in in the north african timeline Sniper
Elite 3 has expanded the environment
significantly so we've actually got
environments which are up to three times
the size of it's not really be - okay
so at the moment obviously we've got
Carl Fairburn here he's laying some
traps he's he's been pretty sneaky at
the moment I'm I suspect this was trying
to cover his tail in case some AI
flanked up into this location and try to
try to get his back what are we playing
this on right now actually whatever what
hardware to be honest I'm not quite sure
what you guys have got set up but we are
out on PlayStation 4 Xbox one
PlayStation 3 Xbox and PC so we're
hitting all five to ten in some ways
this might be ps4 but I'll try to double
check that but okay so what what what's
he doing here he's kind of surveying the
scene is that right yeah at the moment
it looks like he's about to tag a lot of
the AI in the environment we do a
silhouette treatment on the AI now so
you can keep tabs on them keep track of
them so it pays to be methodical and
make sure that you sort of you know
trying to slow things down a bit and
assess things before you just start
shooting away I mean work out well your
targets are before you blow their brains
out Billy yeah we kind of part ourselves
and not being a run and gunner you know
you're supposed to be a thinking man
shooter you're really supposed to sort
of take your time assess the location
it's about to interact with the sniper
nest here so what what that means is he
can you can kick the sound mask on the
right hand side and create a sound
masking agent so when he fires his rifle
the AI won't be able to work out where
he is as quickly now so what did you
what did you kick over there what was
that thingy now he's into a sniper nurse
so this is like one of the early sub
objectives is to take out this general
who's got some intelligence on varlyn
who's out and tagging us in the story
and you know the the thing we try to
promote is the amount of ways you can do
this is a lot of player choices there so
you know obviously he's gone up onto
this ridge line here and he's taking
shots on him
oh wow see you your x-ray cameras back
let's go wait is there a new detail
there there's like some muscles and yeah
we've got all the muscle fibers drawn
now when you're actually going into the
killcam and obviously we're doing a lot
of nice stuff for the tessellation for
the next-gen consoles as well yeah so
that's that's why it's looking as
spectacular as it does there these guys
they didn't hear that there because of
us exactly cuz it's with the sound mask
he's able to get away with it it's it's
kind of like one of the the nice
mechanics we've got we've expanded the
amount of sound masking options
available to the player so you can
sabotage Jennifer it is you can wait for
a plane to fly overhead you know there's
there's lots of different things in the
environment for the player to the
classic Shawshank Redemption
Thunder does ever happen he's smashing
through the pipe in time listen up there
I can I can reveal everything know what
any spoilers oh wow that was through the
ri that was just a great job back there
yes sir at the moment obviously he's
taking the high road
he's doing some sniper shots into the
environment but it could just as easily
stealth down into them we've got a whole
whole bunch of new stealth moves at
night has available to them we have
about four that I want to hear about
your stealth the new stealth kind of
gameplay this at some option well for
the player we never wanted to shoehorn
them into a particular play start we
wanted to make sure that they could play
the game however they wanted so if you
you jump into a radial menu you've got
like a bunch of different traps
available to you that you can use you
know at your disposal you can jump to
s10 machine gun or you can use your
silence well rod you can get down and
dirty in the environment we've got new
traps like the bouncing betty it's a
formidable one for taking out infantry
we've got TNT if we want to use that on
vehicles in the environment but yeah the
stealth components lovely in terms of
attracting the AI now we use something
called the flint and tinder well it does
use to smoke like a small brush fire and
then the AI start to investigate the
fire obviously the fire can interact
with other things in your kit as well so
you can blow up some TNT they come there
to investigate it and I'll still awake
oh my gosh oh lord of you a still line
people up see you then shoot them in the
head pretty much so and where exactly is
this taking place well these ruins it
look like oh yeah this is Gaborone oasis
so we did wrong on the
since but we're taking the player to two
other parts of the world war timeline
obviously world war two North Africa
campaign yeah so you know I mean there's
plenty of variety there for the player
the CEO of Asus which is a bit later on
you guys have got to see that hopefully
soon you know that all these places are
actually real world locations in the
world war timeline it gave us a lot of
you know versatile landscapes to
introduce a player to and and give them
a nice places to hunt down the AI and
have some fun blowing off the Nazi
phases perfect cuz they're all they're
balls
oh they're they're shooting balls is
back is it sniper really three balls is
definitely back it's never gonna leave
it's amazing I mean that's so nice going
to me about sniper really is that you
know shooters is obviously a very
saturated market right but you guys seem
to have finished a car back corner
little niche here for yourself with you
know a third game I mean that doesn't
happen without success so I mean how
much do you think of that is down to
this sniper element this meal to blow up
people skills is x-ray element I mean I
think that's definitely one of our
massive draw cards this is SP for the
product you know for me it's always been
fascinating I look at it almost like
it's kind of medical in in a way you
know it's fascinating to see the inside
of these skeletons but we actually had a
mercenary and we're doing some
correspondence with this guy you know
just making sure all the things that
were introducing the players who make
sense and yeah he basically said that
our kill cam was was worse than reality
when he killed people because he never
had to be so close up to it also that
was quite interesting said these aren't
real people so actually if you guys are
watching at home when you have any
questions about Sniper Elite 3 then the
best thing to do would be to tweet at me
at cam fries Rob and I'll read them up
here live on stage so that's at cam for
as Rob now I still have some questions
though in the meantime so this is part
of the North African campaign and what
made you you know that when you were
planning Sniper Elite 3 decide to come
to this to North Africa I think it was a
nice progression for us so it certainly
gives us expansive environments and like
I said the environments are up to three
times bigger now than they were in in
Sniper Elite v2 but also you know
there's really nice diversity in the
color palette that we can offer the
player there you know
gritty environment in Sniper Elite v2
for the Berlin timeline and now we've
got this like new beautiful orange and
teal like you know just gorgeous
gorgeous colorful and so we can offer
the player you know I think that that's
important that you can mix things up a
bit as well you know you've got so many
different environments around North
Africa to pull the player into that it
always feels fresh and different each
time you're playing a level so that
that's quite exciting for us okay so I'm
I guess one of the one of the no signs
though is you can't shoot Hitler in this
one right or can we
so now we have the pre-order DLC day 1
available which is your hunting the gray
wolf so it was an elusive man and he
actually we have some FBI sketches or it
was sort of like different versions of
what he might have looked like so we're
playing on the fact that you know Hitler
was using doubles and that sort of thing
right you do come in and it's more of a
detective style trying to work out
whether or not you've got the real
Hitler or not before you take the shot
the consequences of the shot obviously
is the whole German army is going to
erupt when you when you assassinate the
Fuehrer so you've got to be you know
assess the clues in the environment work
out whether or not you've got the right
one and then take him down
no wonder is there any vehicles around
here we can shoot because I was seeing
that you've actually introduced your
gonna kill cam to vehicles as well see
see the internal parts of vehicles at
the moment he's overlooking this
Ridgeline here and you can kind of
assess in the environment if he has
vehicles available to him you can you
can take those down and actually see the
internal workings with the kill camera
on the vehicle so I think he's got one
just on the left here you might be able
to get to the weak spot but yeah it
really well miss the joys of a live demo
shoot the vehicle for me going hello /
Federico get up he's getting the
information back from his binoculars
there so it's we highlighted the weak
spot for him now he's zooming in so
we've got dynamic definition of that so
the panel actually breaks away second
shot actually blows up the truck so
sometimes when you do that shot do you
get the also the slow-mo bullet cam into
the engine is that a thing as well yeah
it depends if you've actually done it to
one which is full of they are going to
jump out as well we've read this game
I'm so sorry
everyone knows he's there that's alright
well does she listen to me we do like
the champion it's not
as a plea session you is is it should
can go loud that's fine you can relocate
if things kick off and and you can
actually get things back on your own
terms so that's something we like to
really you know we don't want players
did not feel like that they can't you
know get a plea session back you get a
lot of that sort of style of game play
people compromise to stealthily say you
know you don't have to do that you can
you can actually go relocate get things
back on your own terms and we also have
a full save suite as well so if you want
to save at this exact moment if you just
push pause go to save and then you put a
staple of it and you know this or even
if it's just you saving your favorite
moment you yeah you know exactly what
you were doing where you were what was
going on who which is quite cool but he
seems to be handling this quite well you
know even though it's kicked up like did
I see I thought so is there like a last
position indicator or anything exactly
say yeah there it is yeah we're
highlighting the lkp so what you can do
is use that to your advantage if you
want you can attract a lot of attention
and then the AI or of us you had to come
up you've got awareness of where they're
coming to
you can't wrap that up and play some you
know nice of cat and mouse when they
arrive if they don't know where you are
we're using a lot of the foliage systems
as well to to make you less visible to
the AI so they weren't choir you as
quickly if using shadows if you're in
amongst the foliage you know trying to
use these things to your advantage
rather than you know just again we're
not running gun you need to try and
think about things as you playing this
and make sure that you know you take a
calculated and thinking man's approach
to this cool so what's the ultimate part
of this mission
so who me after here so Gabbar and Oasis
we're trying to you know find out more
information about violin and there's a
little his main generals are in this
area so we're we're blowing
assassinating all these generals and
we're taking the intelligence off their
corpse which is going to help us work
out you know where are years what he's
up to in north bow wow where did that
even go I was it was pretty pretty
brutal oh yeah yeah I think we've
definitely made this hard for as a Josh
he's playing so no see the relocation
distance ticking down so as he's running
away the further he runs he can actually
get that relocation distance to burn
down and then you know we try to there's
a bit of a delicate balance so you don't
want the AI just go well it's not here
job done yeah
get there they actually do if I split up
they'll do a search for you they'll try
and find you in the area and if they
come and find you at that point they'll
say okay they won't reset to just
passive like oh god I don't know what's
going on there's no one around here
there resets a passive cautious so what
that means is that a jeté tur they're
suspicious things have happened you know
people have died around them they
shouldn't just be going back and having
a conversation about you know the
weather or so they will be kind of
keeping their eyes peeled for you yeah
we keep them in our agitator today so
once so once these have revealed
yourself it never quite goes back to how
it was before then yeah but you still
can empower yourself to take it on again
I mean that rule if if he relocates at
the moment that we fan out finish that
search and it goes through an old coil
then it's more just the animation state
which is different too and this behavior
is slightly more suspicious so they'll
look a bit more agitated but that they
will have properly deescalate at that
point allowing you to get back cat and
mouse sneak around and you know you're
not gonna see them all you know in
combat forever so what's the deciding
factor - oh did we just die I've been
used on we just die well that's what
happens yeah if you take on a fish if
you shoot up trucks when people tell you
to don't do that make mistake so what's
the deciding factor when you when you
bill for headshots getting the kill
camera or not it's it just is every time
it's a clean head shot gives you that
kill cam we wanted to make sure they're
a bit of a reward for the player so so
something that you just have to have all
the time but you know depending on the
distance that you killed the map for
example and you know what you shot
whether or not you've done a critical
hit region on the body on whether or not
you've hit them in the head the more
distance the more showy the sort of kill
camera is going to be just to just to
basically reward the player for their
awesome work awesome let's have a quick
check on Twitter and see if you guys
have been a handing me out with some
questions we just get back there do we
have any questions on Twitter I hope so
it's fine if not because I got a Louis
tomorrow here we go yes okay
loads of geez loads of questions in fat
so and have you changed the coop have
you in have you mr. co-op this time
around as well we definitely have come
up this time around so we've also got
multiplayer straight out of the bag on
launch day so you've got a bunch of
different modes there coop single-player
campaign you've also got survivor and
overwatch returning survivors kind of
like that horde style game kay but
obviously we've got all these new
vehicles coming at the player to tutu's
half-tracks Ganz's Tigers and then the
the overwatch gameplay reunites the
sniper and the operative in there in
there to sort of separate roles so you
get down and dirty is the operative and
start like posting people down with the
stem machine-gun if you want while the
snipers whistling bullets over your head
you might be more calculated getting
there you know with your world rod which
is an old antique silenced pistol from
the era you know start taking people out
rather stealthily and then he's using
sound masking over your head taking
people out you know no one knows where
either of you are in that case so again
play a choice trying to make sure that
people and play the certain way you know
there's nothing to say they might just
grab a panzerschreck and start you know
blowing everyone up you know that that's
entirely up to them as well but and
that's that's also that was like was a
question by the way from Black Mesa but
Andrew Barnett asks can you switch the
side you're aiming when you're in
third-person switching the side your
feet for example if you was to click a
button or whatever I don't really have
insurance which Thomas Jones which okay
so no shoulder switch another question
here we go is there any way of changing
the imperium the appearance eg clothes
of the main character it's certainly a
parent Lee Josh would like to be able to
change his his clothes
maybe potential for something in the
future
fashion of the war perhaps we do allow
the players to to play as any of the the
characters they see in the game for the
multiplayer so when you're jumping on
attacking your friends blowing each
other away with your sniper rifles you
can choose from and maybe play as well
in one of the you know the bad guys or
you can get him with a ghillie suit you
know run around and so there's there's
lots of customization options at the
multiplayer but for the single-player
campaign you're playing his Carlo burnin
and he doesn't you know dress up he's
just down and dirty sly but what's his
story
what's what's his backstory he is
basically I mean we we play on the fact
that snipers were actually kind of
feared even by the there
men and you know and they kind of like a
very solitary characters and Carl is
essentially just a worker of war so he
gets things done and he's very good at
killing people and you know that that's
just what he does is and you know for us
to kind of explore I guess some of the
reasons that made him the way he is
we've gone back in time now for Sniper
Elite 3 so obviously the Carl's
character was quite vanilla and you know
the reason that he's just such a
methodical worth ago kind of comes a bit
to the fore in this one we explain why
you know maybe he's just not actually
you know going to try and reach out to
the world and establish relationships
with people anymore he's he's
potentially gonna see some of that in
this timeline oh there we go there again
so if you added into some us and you
killcams some new parts of the body yuki
shoots the the regions themselves in
terms of the critical hit regions have
all been fully fleshed out obviously
we've got that you know internal muscle
layer and all this sort of defamation
now as well so the bullet will always
carve a unique path through that
skeleton and it will deform in unique
ways as well which is quite cool but
yeah we've basically you know made sure
that you can still incapacitate the AI
as well so if you wanted to actually
draw their friends out to them to try
and heal that person if you'd like to
shot them in the leg or something of
blown away you know that part of them
they it's going to pulling people out to
that person they have a sort of
weighting system as well so if they
sense a lot of their friends have died
in in in a certain region then they they
basically look at that way pointed space
and go that doesn't look like a good
place to be and they'll actually flank
around that sort of high def zone and
trying to try to get out you in
different ways rather than just always
going to the same place we've got other
one where is this one gonna go it's
another headshot nice very good yeah I
don't think we've had any bowl shots
though I feel like it wouldn't it
wouldn't be a demo of Sniper Elite we
didn't have at least one that's your
challenge game player alright go for it
here comes oh no that certainly looked
painful but it was might be money just
on the money when else we agreement and
it
why do I want to see this that was lower
intestine yeah
pretty pretty brutal thusly involvement
in there that was quite brutal yeah so
there and I guess does it all depend on
kind of the ragdoll physics as well this
stuff all comes together to to work on
the path of the bullet I mean I mean in
terms of how does the body react to way
gets shot these things aren't
pre-scripted right it's a no-no it's
always gonna happen you know differently
like like you know obviously with a
Azurill attacker now our physics that we
have you know there's gonna be different
reactions from from the body based on
the bullets trajectory you know the
velocity the distance all these factors
are gonna come into play
yeah to have a different result on the
on the AI after the shot looks like he's
mercilessly hunting that that yeah you
know you could do it
I believe that's good though it's
interesting he's bringing up now it's
either kill 35 X be premeditated so
obviously depending on how you're
playing the game we reward the player
with with higher XP bonuses for
different playstyles so if you run
around with a stem machine gun and shoot
everyone in the face yeah not gonna cure
a lot of XP but if you are running
around with the sniper rifle sound
masking your shots relocating shooting
from a new position you're gonna earn
much more XP and then you can actually
customize your rifle and start to unlock
a whole new suite of traps and different
things to attack the AI with and the
great thing about that as well as any of
the XP that you're occurring in the
single-player campaign and the
customizations you made to your rifle
you can then take that rifle online for
the multiplayer the brings would you
spend mercilessly hours hunting for the
perfect ball chart and then get a really
great rifle you can take that it tell
online exactly do have to be careful
because if you drop that rifle someone
else can pick it up and then use it on
you for the duration of rammer I had
lost their they could you know you've
not lost it yeah you used to yeah you
get to keep that but all the XP that
you're occurring in multiplayer as well
will unlock things for the single player
campaign so we try to you know keep it
really nice and freeform though so
because this entire game is set in the
African campaign how did you guys make
sure that was still kind of variety in
your in your locations that must move a
challenge because everything's kind of
desert I guess it was like our choices
of environments we made sure that you
know we took a player to new locations
all throughout the missions you the the
journey that you take throughout the
North African campaign you know as I
said earlier the environment has a lot
of diversity there so I don't want to
spoil anything for you guys but you know
there's a really nice sort of you know
influences that we draw from the classic
films like Indiana Jones and that sort
of thing where yeah you know we're
showing up some of these you know really
nice beautiful environments obviously
we're very the time of day as well so
you always get a new color palette there
you know I think some people have had
hands-on with Hellfire one of one of our
you know amazing large larger massive
environments and you know it's just the
richness of color and the beauty in that
environment amazing the artists at
rebellion have done an amazing job so
you've been and producing this for it's
both current well I guess current gen is
next to pay what could tell me the
platforms and you know to play the son
that's a much better question what
platforms people get hold of a sniper
early on so of course you can get hold
of it on PC but we've got both
next-generation consoles for PlayStation
4 Xbox one but we're also coming out on
PlayStation 3 and the Xbox 360 okay and
you get the same experience across all
those platforms but of course with the
next-generation consoles you get your
bindings with the controllers you also
get you know the nice tessellation
DirectX 11 you know all these sorts of
things is really HD scale breaking
village because we're also 1080p on both
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
yeah so that's that's nice that we got
that one out of the bag my proud of that
it looks really great and what engine is
this built in actually this says it's
unreal tech no no so this is our own
engine rebellions is called the zero
tech so the guys work really hard
internally to make sure that that's you
know looking slick and we're pretty
proud of the stuff that we've done for
the next-generation consoles and and
also proof proud of you know how far we
push the PlayStation 3 and the Xbox 360
you know we've got way more AI running
around this time and as I say you do get
the same experience on on both the next
gen and previous generation consoles
which we're proud of as well
fantastic so loads people pretty much
anyone with a console and get their
hands on this then exactly know I'm
speaking of which when when is the
release day when can you your hands on
this so we've got July first
so really first yeah it's quite some
time all right
we've got a nice timeline there cuz we
there's not so much out at the moment
and I think sniper stands out from the
crowd as well we got positive feedback
today nice because I'm pretty much every
game of had on stage that be really
excited about it's been like 2015 and
yes not this one that's fantastic you've
got days mate you can't no good
so get remember guys if you have any
more questions we've we're almost about
out of time but if you have any more
questions please do throw them in on
Twitter I'm at camp Fras Rob where I got
time for a wall or two more at the most
see see what else I had something else I
really wanted to ask you about better
stealth combat so you were mentioning
that you can obviously you can use sound
distractin to to lure your enemies
around yeah what about like kind of
cover in mechanics of you and you could
anything you in there yes but we've got
a dynamic cover system now so as you
moves over to the cover here what we
actually have is feedback in the player
character that you know they're
interacting with the cover he's sort of
leaning in against it letting you know
that he's starting to move so that's
free form you don't actually have to
bind to that you can just walk up take
the benefits of it and then you walk
away you detach seamlessly so that's not
something that you have to commit to we
wanted something which was you know as
freeform as possible for the players you
know when things can go bad so quickly
and our eye is so formidable we wanted
to make sure that you know you weren't
stuck to cover or trying to release or
something like that you know you can
just get in get out move around vault
over this cover you know there's lots of
interactions in the environment
fantastic well let's end this on one
more fantastic kill no pressure no
pressure you never playing it's better
be the best one it's better be that
elusive shot him after yeah no pressure
where is he going he's I think he's
looking you might have already killed
everyone
have you killed everybody have you
actually already killed everyone okay
you gotta save one for the finale he's
looking if you can get the general from
here this would be quite sure come on
give it no no no if he's going out of
sight I think those rocks are in the way
well you know what that's a valiant
effort we've had I'm probably just being
greedy we've had so many wonderful kills
but I thank you so much for joining this
stage man for sure we're for a show bill
III think it's a really good fun it's
been great to see it running on on
brand-new tech as well and yes so that's
just once again for everyone weren't
gonna get their hands on Sniper Elite 3
July 1st month July 1st join for a well
guys think you saw
much first sticking with us all day
today on both across our two stages
you've had you guys here in the Samsung
stage and over on the GameSpot stage as
well but it's about time now just throw
to our final thing of the day which is
our GameSpot wrap show but remember to
come back tomorrow we're gonna have ton
more live demos across our live stages
so we will of course see you then over
to the wrap show